le projet Doig de Finance est un texte
fondamental nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui dans une situation que nous
connaissons malheureusement toutes et
tous notre pays a besoin d'un budget et
les oppositions ne souhaitent pas
trouver de compromis avec nous pour
l'adopter aussi sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur l'ensemble du projet de
Doig de finance pour 2024 je vous
remercie bonjour à tous et bienvenue
dans les grands débats chaque automne à
l'Assemblée les députés se consacrent à
l'examen du budget un vrai marathon sauf
en majorité relative voter un budget
c'est appartenir à une majorité et il en
est tort de question pour les
oppositions reste alors au gouvernement
qu'un outil pour faire adopter le texte
l'article 49 al 3 de la Constitution
nous sommes le 18 octobre 2023 Elisabeth
borne arrive à l'Assemblée
nationale s'il vous plaît la parole est
à madame la Première
ministre présidente monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
vous si vous connaissez la procédure
vous savez que c'est la parole est à
madame la Première ministre et que vous
n'avez pas la parole donc je vous
remercie de vous taire monsieur Boyard
madame la Première ministre madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs
les
députés le projet Doig de Finance est un
texte
fondamental c'est c'est la clé de voûte
de nos politiques publiques c'est la
réponse aux préoccupations des
Françaises et des
Français ce sont des moyens pour le
pouvoir d'achat pour le plein emploi
pour la transition écologique pour nos
services publics et pour l'ordre
républicain sur tous ces points ce
budget présente des avancées majeures
c'est un budget pour nos armées pour
notre sécurité intérieure pour notre
justice auquel nous consacrons des
moyens inédits des moyens dont le
contexte actuel nous rappellent combien
ils sont nécessaires combien nous en
avons besoin pour protéger les Français
c'est un budget vert il permet
d'accélérer la transition écologique en
y consacrant des moyens sans précédent
41 milliards d'euros l'année prochaine
c'est 7 milliards d'euros de plus que
cette année c'est un budget pour notre
école avec une revalorisation historique
de nos enseignants une augmentation de
125 € minimum par mois j'ajoute que
c'est un budget de cohérence il
maintient le cap de notre politique
économique et met en acte notre
engagement pas de hausse d'impôt nous
continuons même à diminuer les impôts de
production avec une nouvelle baisse d'un
milliard d'euros notre objectif est
inchangé supprimer totalement la CVAE
d'ici la fin du
quinquena c'est enfin un budget de
il respecte notre trajectoire de
réduction des déficits publics avec 16
milliards d'euros d'économie l'en
prochain mesdames et messieurs les
députés pour ce budget comme pour les
précédents nous avons tendu la main et
chercher des points
d'accord nous avons
[Applaudissements]
discuté nous avons discutter avec tous
les
groupes
nous avons discuté avec tous les groupes
notamment dans le cadre des dialogues de
Bery nous avons enfin accepté de faire
évoluer notre texte en reprenant des
amendements de la majorité comme des
oppositions je pense à l'assouplissement
des conditions d'accès au pré àau zéro
qui sera désormais ouvert à 6 millions
de Français je pense à l'abattement
exceptionnel pour les plus-values
foncières pour libérer des terrains à
bâtir je pense à la lutte contre la
fraude ou encore au renforcement des
dispositifs d'aide au carburant pour les
travailleurs cependant aujourd'hui le
constat est clair aucun groupe
d'opposition n'est prêt à voter ce
projet de loi de financeces
or or notre
pays or notre pays a besoin de ce budget
nous avons besoin de cette première
partie du PLF pour financer nos projets
et et les réponses au défis auquels nous
faisons
face s'il vous
plaît alors ça n'a rien de drôle je vous
demande de respecter madame la Première
ministre le respect c'est un minimum
dans cette je sais pas si vous prenez
modèle monsieur le député sur l'autre
bord de l'hémicycle ça fait assez peu
progresser le
[Applaudissements]
débat
allez un peu de silence vous laissez
madame la première ministreexprimer
madame la Première ministre aut comme à
chaque fois comme à chaque fois que ce
que ce sera
nécessaire j'agirai en conscience et
dans l'intérêt du pays et des
[Musique]
Français aussi sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur la première partie du
projet de loi de finan pour 2024 je vous
remercie beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
ministre 1 493 sur le projet de loi de
finance ce n'est plus une surprise on a
connu la saison 2023 mais là il
intervient juste après la discussion
générale avant même la discussion des
articles les opposition arrive aux
quatre colonnes pour le
dénoncer on est évidemment pas surpris
par le 493 mais il y a quand même une
surprise c'est que le gouvernement
innove même en matière de
493 parce que je crois pas qu'on ait
déclenché un 493 un jour sur un budget
avant même qu'on ait commencé l'examen
des articles donc bravo à l'innovation
gouvernementale j'avoue que là je le dis
d'autant plus avec un peu d'humour mais
les débats en commission ont été très
très sereins pendant 4 jours 4 nuits et
surtout en déclenchant ce 493 aussitôt
ce que je leur reproche évidemment c'est
de priver les Français d'un débat le
compromis il pouvait le trouver ici à
l'Assemblée nationale où on le sait ils
n'ont pas de majorité
mais où une majorité était capable de se
décider pour plus de justice fiscale
pour plus de recette pour répondre aux
besoins des Français ils viennent de le
refuser je dois dire que ils ajoutent
donc à la méthode du 493 une méthode de
fermeture du débat une une méthode du
passage en force et je ne crois pas que
c'est mauvais évidemment pour la
démocratie mais je ne crois pas qu'à
long terme ça soit très longtemps
tenable comme forme de gouvernement je
voulais d'abord vous dire que le 493
c'est évidemment un échec un échec à
construire des consensus c'est ce que
j'ai dit d'ailleurs avec les
parlementaires de mon groupe hier à la
première ministre et il n'est pas
question pour nous de d'accepter qu'on
puisse continuer à banalyser le 493
écoutez certes nous savions que le
gouvernement allait utiliser ce 493 mais
pas quand même si tôt c'est quand même
un aveu de d'absence totale de respect
pour le Parlement une absence totale de
respect pour le débat il y a même pas
une volonté de de tenter d'entendre les
oppositions et une fois plus madame LEB
borne pardon ment et elle ment gravement
quand elle dit qu'elle reprend des
amendements des oppositions qu'ils ont
comment dire tendu la main aux
oppositions moi je l'ai dit hein après
les dialogues de Bery que tout ça était
une mise en
scène en réponse à ce 493 deux motions
de censure sont déposées une par une
partie de l'anupes l'autre par le
rassemblement national elles sont
défendues 48 he plus
tard bonsoir à tous la séance est
ouverte l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion commune une des motions de
censure déposé en application de
l'article 49 aléa 3 de la Constitution
par Madame Marine Le Pen et 87 membres
de l'Assemblée d'une part et par Madame
Mathilde Panau et sans de membes de
l'Assemblée d'autre part la première
ministre ayant engagé la responsabilité
du Gouvernement sur l'adoption de la
première partie du projet de loi de
finances pour 2024 à Madame Alexandra
Masson pour le rassemblement nationale
pour une durée maximale de 15
minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci zéro c'est le nombre d'articles de
la première partie de ce projet de loi
de finance qui aura été examiné dans cet
hémicycle zéro c'est aussi le nombre
d'amendements qui aura été débattu ici
dans cet
hémicycle zéro c'est également notre
manque de respect pour la représentation
nationale et pour le peuple français
pour la 13e fois vous utilisez l'article
493 de la Constitution pour masquer vos
faiblesses depuis votre arrivée à
Matignon déjà vos partisans tentent de
banaliser ce 13e passage en force c'est
un non événement les Français ont
intégré que l'on avait pas de majorité
absolue et que pour les textes
budgétaires nous devions passer par un
493 à juger quand même votre
porte-parole de
renaissance Nadia et un non événement
madame la Première ministre merci
d'arriver quel mépris pour le peuple
français quel mépris pour les collègues
si si quel mépris c'est évidemment bien
davantage et vous le
savez c'est un sauf qui peu après la
débandade de l'examen de votre projet de
loi en commission de finances si vous
vouliez madame la Première ministre tâer
le terrain et bien vous avez été servi
faute de majorité les votes en
commission se sont traduits par une
série de défaites pour votre
gouvernement la commission des finances
a rejeté l'ensemble du texte et pour
cause ce projet de loi de finances pour
2024 marque la 50e année de déficit
public continue vous n'avez donc aucune
leçon de gestion à nous donner malgré
l'autosatisfaction et les bons points
qui ne cesse de s'attribuer le ministre
de l'Économie Bruno Le Maire devant
cette assemblée ou les plateaux
télévisés
la France va devoir lever 285 milliards
d'euros d'endettement pour financer son
déficit et une dette habissale qui
représente près de 110 % du PIB la
parole est à monsieur le Président
cqurel pour le groupe la France
[Applaudissements]
insoumise madame la
Présidente madame la Première ministre
messieurs dames les ministres chers
collègues vous battez de tristes records
madame borne vous détenez désormais
celui du plus grand nombre de 493
déclenché sur des textes budgétaires de
toute l'histoire de la 5e République un
palmarès qui risque encore de s'alourdir
avec votre projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale battu hier en
commission et pour la partie dépens du
projet de loi de finan je me demande
bien ce que cela vous fait fa d'établir
ce type de record fineste madame madame
la Première ministre d'être à la tête
d'un gouvernement qui a 13 reprises en à
peine un an retire des mains de
l'Assemblée nationale son rôle le plus
fondamental le vote et encore plus
spécifiquement le vote du budget un
gouvernement qui a 13 reprises en à
peine un an choisit de faire passer en
force des textes qui n'avaient pas de
majorité c'est bien une drôle d'habitude
que vous avez prise vous qui vous
plaisez tant à vous prendre pour un
curseur de la République capable de
déterminer à votre convenance qui se
situe ou non dans l'arc républicain quel
ironie de vous voir manier sans relâche
le 493 l'arc le moins républicain qui
soit celui qui prive les représentants
du peuple de l'exercice de sa
souveraineté je sais bien que la 5e
République vous y autorise ça n'en fait
pas pour autant un bon outil ni un
principe de fonctionnement acceptable
pour une démocratie au contraire ça
confirme l'idée que cette 5e République
est dépassée dysfonctionnelle
irrespectueuse du pouvoir parlementaire
et des principes démocrati de base et
qu'il est grand temps de fonder
collectivement une 6e république enfin
débarrassée de ce type de vestige
autoritaire qui est le
493 les différents groupes politiques
donnent à présent leur position sur ces
motions de
censure suite madame la Première
ministre à votre 13e 49 3 cette
situation devient usuelle mais ce qu'
est moins c'est le moment que vous avez
choisi pour y recourir et c'est bien là
tout le problème car pour la première
fois vous n'avez laissé aucune je dis
bien aucune place au débat rendez-vous
compte que sur cette première partie de
PLF en séance pas un seul amendement
n'aura été discuté pas un seul
amendement n'aura été soumis au vote pas
un seul article n'aura été adopté pas un
seul article n'aura été soumis à notre
vote car avant d'être exercice comptable
le budget est le réceptable des attentes
des inquiétudes et des espérances de nos
compatriotes en même temps qu'une
traduction législative de nos priorités
pour le pays le cœur de notre travail de
législateur c'est donc de relayer les
demandes des Français et notre seul
moyen de le faire c'est en défendant nos
amendements ici dans l'hémicycle par nos
amendements nous voulions parler de
pouvoir d'achat nous voulions parler du
prix des carburants de baisse d'impôt de
réduction des dépenses publiques par nos
amendements nous voulions tenter d'AM il
aurait le sort des Familles de France
des entreprises et des collectivités qui
tout à leur niveau souffrent face à une
inflation dont n nous voyons pas le bout
or vous nous privez aujourd'hui de ce
droit d'amendement vous ne nous
permettez pas de nous exprimer sur le
texte le plus important du calendrier
parlementaire non nous ne voterons pas
ces motions de censure n'en déplaise à
notre collègue Alexandra Masson du
rassemblement national qui s'est exprimé
juste avant pour autant les républicains
ne donnent aucun blancin au gouvernement
loin de là loin de là nous avons voté
contre la loi de programmation des
finances publiques en première lecture
nous avons voté contre le PLF 2024 en
commission des finances nous avons voté
contre le PLF SS 2024 ce jour en
commission des affaires sociales je vous
remercie madame la Présidente et nous
restons des opposant déterminés fidèles
à nos convictions nous continuerons de
défendre une troème voix différente de
responsabilité des extrêmes et ce avec
une vision alternative de ce que devrait
être les orientations budgétaires de
notre pays je vous
remerci c'est assez c'est assez cocasse
parce que vous n'avez pas la majorité
pour faire passer un texte donc vous
êtes obligé d'utiliser le 493
normalement ça veut dire que le
Parlement n'est pas majoritaire pour
vous mais on narrive pas non plus à
avoir une majorité sur une motion de
sensure donc personne n'arrive à avoir
de
majorité
mais
en mais en fait pour une raison qui est
simple c'est que peut-être ceux qui
peuvent faire la bascule ne veulent pas
retourner aux urnes parce que forcément
ils ont peur de ne pas pouvoir
repasser et en fait c'est ça la la
réelle question c'est c'est
que ceux qui peuvent faire la bascule
dans dans cette dans cette
émicycle ils ont peur de se confronter
au
peuple alors bon vous avez bien compris
que le groupe GDR ira jusqu'au bout et
votera la motion de
censure parce que finalement je je pense
alors moi je suis arrivé que la semaine
dernière
euh mais mais mes collègues Jean-Marc et
Nicolas sensu étaient là depuis le début
en en commission des
finances ils ont
réussi les oppositions ont réussi à ne
pas faire voter et le PLF et le
PLFSS mais je pense que c'est parce
qu'il y a une démobilisation de la
majorité parce que vous savez qu'il
allit avoir un
493 mais
finalement vous vous avez un
493 et nous on a que des amendements
pour pouvoir nous exprimer c'est vous
qui créez le texte c'est vous que les
qui qui qui le mettez en place et c'est
vous vous qui ont décidé les tenants et
les aboutissants et nous on décide plus
rien finalement ça se décide tout dans
les ministères et j'espère qu'un jour
dans cette mandature on puisse
voter une loi de finance dans ce
Parlement madame la Présidente euh
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les députés messieurs mesdames
et messieurs les ministres ce n'est pas
un hasard si les deux motions de censure
que nous débattons ce soir ont été
déposés par ceux qui n'ont proposé
aucune alternative crédiible au projet
de budget présenté par votre
gouvernement
oui vos éclats de voix et vos
gesticulations cache mal le vide
programmatique qui est le vôtre des deux
côtés de cet
hémicycle tout à l'heure madame maçon
madame maçon nous dit nous n'avons avec
des trémolos dans la voie nous n'avons
pas discutter des
amendements nous n'avons pas discuté des
amendements avec une litanie sur les
zéos enchaîné vous savez quoi l'année
dernière à la même date vous nous avez
dit exactement l'inverse nous passons du
temps ici en hémicycle et au fond ça ne
sert à rien vous êtes totalement vous
dites tout et son contraire totalement
incohérent et de l'autre
côté le président coqurel qui arrive et
je le remercie nous a dit pareil avec
les mêmes trémolo que nous avions voté
que vous aviez voté 38 amendements vous
les avez longuement détaillé contre
l'avis du rapporteur général et à la fin
vous votez contre le budget à la fin
votez nous avons voté le budget vous
avez voté contre le budget vous êtes
irresponsable vous nous appelez à
travailler avec nous vous ne proposez
rien et à la fin vous votez
contre notre groupe ne soutiendra aucune
de ces deux motions de censure qui ne
vise qu'une chose semer le chaos encore
et toujours dans notre
pays ellisabeth borne prend la parole
sur ces deux motions de censure la
première ministre renvoie dos à dos
l'extrême droite et l'extrême
gauche la parole est à madame la
Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre dans ce débat nocturne j'ai
entendu beaucoup exactitude pour ne pas
dire de
contevérité beaucoup d'exagération pour
ne pas dire
d'outrance beaucoup de postures pour ne
pas dire de mauvaise
foi mais une chose me marque plus que
tout une fois de plus tout à l'heure le
rassemblement national et la France
insoumise voteront
ensemble je ne m'en étonne plus c'est
devenu une
habitude
pourtant
pourtant pourtant je me suis penché sur
les textes de vos motions de
censure et le moins que l'on puisse dire
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que vous ne faites pas la même lecture
du budget à l'extrême droite on nous
parle de hausse d'impôt quand à
l'extrême gauche on nous on nous
reproche au contraire de les baisser à
l'extrême droite on ment en affirmant
que ce budget ne prévoit aucune
quant à l'extrême gauche on invente au
contraire une trajectoire
[Musique]
d'austérité de ces constats de ces
constats de ces constats je tire trois
conclusions la première c'est que vous
partagez la même culture de la démagogie
vous mentez au
[Applaudissements]
français nous dégageons des moyens
exceptionnel pour nos armées pour nos
forces de l'ordre pour notre justice
pour la transition écologique pour
l'école comment osez-vous parler d'un
budget
d'austérité nous avons baissé l'impôt
sur le revenu pour les premières
tranches supprimer la redevance
audiovisuelle supprimer la taxe
d'habitation baisser les impôts de
production et nous le faisons encore
dans ce budget alors comment osez-vous
parler de hausse de la pression fiscale
ce sont des baisses d'impôts massives
plus qu'aucune majorité avant nous ce
sont des baisses d'impôts pour les
français et notamment les classes
moyennes nous baissons de 16 milliards
d'euros ns dépenses en 2024 et nous
tenons le cap pour passer sous les 3 %
de déficit d'ici 2027 grâce à la réforme
des retraites grâce à la réforme de
l'assurance chômage que vous n'avez pas
voter mesdames et messieurs les députés
du rassemblement national alors comment
osez-vous parler de déficit en Haus la
responsabilité budgétaire c'est
[Applaudissements]
NOUS VOUS
PLAÎT mesdames et messieurs les
députés ma deuxème conclusion c'est que
vous partagez le même goût pour
l'outrance la même quête d'instabilité
vous multipliez les injures les
incidents de séance les crit et nous
avons vu mercredi soir et encore ce soir
et encore ce soir qu'il n'était pas
l'apanage de la France insoumise vous
n'avez ni proposition ni solution pour
les Français votre seul objectif c'est
de faire tomber le gouvernement vous
n'avez ni ni majorité ni budget
alternatif pour la France vous voulez
uniquement le blocage et le
chaos
[Applaudissements]
la troisième conclusion que je tire
devant cette union sacrée des extrême
c'est que le gouvernement est sur la
bonne voie quand chaque extrême nous
fait des reproches inverses c'est que
nous tenons la voix de l'équilibre votre
programme c'est la démagogie et le chaos
notre programme c'est l'action et les
solutions
mesdames et messieurs les députés
engager la responsabilité du
gouvernement ne se fait jamais ni avec
légèreté ni par
facilité je le fais par devoir parce que
la France ne peut pas se passer d'un
budget parce que nous avons besoin de
cette première partie du projet de loi
de finance pour accompagner les Français
et pour faire fonctionner nos services
publics pour payer nos enseignants nos
policiers nos gendarmes nos magistrats
j'ai engagé la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement en conscience car il
n'existe pas d'autres majorité capable
de faire adopter un budget sur ces
bancs j'ai engagé la responsabilité de
mon gouvernement par conviction s'il
vous plaît car je crois dans ce budget
et dans les solutions qu'il porte ce
projet de loi de finance met en acte les
priorités de notre action protéger le
pouvoir d'achat de nos compatriotes
mener la transition écologique atteindre
le plein emploi améliorer la qualité de
nos services public et garantir l'ordre
républicain les deux motions sont
largement rejetées place maintenant à la
deuxième partie du projet de loi de
finances celle sur les dépenses les
députés examinent les crédits àoués à la
justice à l'école à la défense mais ils
n'iront pas jusqu'au bout
puisqueélisabeth borne et de retour dans
l'hémicycle la séance est
[Applaudissements]
reprise et la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général du budget
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les
députés après avoir examiné
l'intégralité de la deuxième partie du
projet de doit de finance en
commission après en avoir débattu
pendant plus de 40 he en
séance nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui
dans une situation que nous connaissons
malheureusement toutes et
tous d'abord la discussion de ce PLF se
déroule à un rythme particulièrement
lent
s'il vous plaît s'il vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plaît l'examen l'examen de la moitié des
missions l'examen de la moitié des
missions n'a pas pu aller à son
terme si des
échanges si les échanges se poursuivent
à ce rythme il ne fait aucun doute que
nous ne pourrons pas achever l'examen de
ce projet de Boix de finance dans les
temps
ensuite ensuite lors de l'examen de
certaines missions le texte a pu être
dénaturé des milliards d'euros de
dépenses des milliards d'euros de
dépenses ont été ajouté hier nous
présentons un budget ambitieux avec les
investissements nécessaires pour chacune
de nos politiques
publiques
nos invtissements pour l'école pour
notre sécurité intérieure pour notre
justice ou nos armées je pense à
l'investissement inédit que nous menons
en faveur de la transition écologique 40
milliards d'euros l'année prochaine 7
milliards d'euros de plus que cette
année c'est
inédit mais ces investissements massifs
ne sont ne sont possibles que parce
qu'ils s'inscrivent dans une trajectoire
budgétaire soutenable une trajectoire
budgétaire qui nous permet de revenir
sous les 3 % de déficit public à
l'horizon
2027 c'est nécessaire pour notre
crédibilité c'est impératif pour notre
souveraineté enfin malgré notre volonté
de trouver des points d'accord aucun des
groupes d'opposition ne semble vouloir
sortir de sa position de principe
rejeter le budget quoi qu'il contienne
je m'en désole mais j'en prends acte
nous continuerons toujours et encore à
chercher des compromis y compris sur les
textes
budgétaire et une fois de plus et une
fois de plus nous avons choisi de
reprendre des amendements de la majorité
comme des
oppositions des
amendements des amendements qui vont
permettre des investissements
supplémentaires dans les outremerses
notamment pour les infrastructures du
quotidien pour l'emploi ou pour la
rénovation des réseaux
d'eau des amendements qui vont étendre
l'indemnité carburant à 60 % des
Français qui travaille pour qu'elle
bénéficie mieux encore aux classes
moyennes des amendements qui vont
permettre d'accentuer encore notre lutte
contre le harcellement scolaire
d'instaurer un budget vert pour les
collectivités de renforcer la lutte
contre la pauvreté de financer des
campagne de testing contre les
discriminations de mieux prévenir les
risques liés à la pollution ou encore de
renforcer les moyens de la recherche sur
les cancers
pédiatriques des amendements qui vont
renforcer les moyens du Mémorial de la
Choa dans cette période où les actes
antisémites augmentent faire vivre le
devoir de mémoire est d'autant plus
nécessaire mesdames et messieurs les
députés nous ne pouvons pas priver la
France de budget nous ne pouvons pas
priver nos concitoyens de leur services
public et des solutions qu'il
attendent nous le pouvons d'autant moins
que nous savons bien qu'il n'existe
aucune majorité alternative capable de
s'entendre autour d'un
budget aussi sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur la 2è partie et
l'ensemble du projet doit de finance
pour 2024 je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre l'Assemblée nationale
prend acte de l'engagement de la
responsabilité du gouvernement
conformément aux dispositions de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
[Applaudissements]
Constitution face à ce nouveau 493 c'est
devenu automatique les insoumis
défendent une motion de censure dans un
hémicycle
clairsemé madame la présidente mesdames
et messieurs les ministres chers
collègues madame la première ministre
dégager dégageer du balai dehors ça
suffit voilà ce que nous vous disons
avec notre motion de censure voilà ce
que vous disent avec nous des millions
de Français qui chantent Macron
démission partez madame la Première
ministre car vous abîmez la France et sa
république vous en avez encore fait la
démonstration il y a 2 jours avec votre
16e 493 nos compatriotes doivent savoir
comment ça s'est passé car vous avez
transformé l'Assemblée nationale en
théâtre de marionnette je vous raconte
la pièce 23h40 la séance est suspendue
on va changer de décor vous entrez dans
l'hémicycle avec un grand sourire on
change de présidente de séance tout est
en place pour la pièce de théâtre à
23h48 ça commence la présidente de
l'Assemblée vous convoque à la tribune
elle se marre le public des marionnettes
macronistes se lève et applaudit à tout
rompre sa propre mise à mort
parlementaire puis vous parlez triomphal
sur de votre force vous connaissez votre
texte par cœur puisque vous l'avez déjà
fait 15 fois sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement blab blabla à 23h52 4
minutes plus tard c'est déjà fini fin de
la pièce rideau applaudissement des
marionnettes vous ne faites même plus
semblant d'en avoir quelque chose à
faire vous écrabouillez l'Assemblée
nationale en 4 minutes chrono avec un
grand sourire vous piétinez le Parlement
et vous vous en amuser pour vous c'est
devenu un jeu rien de plus mais ce n'est
pas un jeu
ce n'est pas un jeu madame la Première
ministre car vous détruisez la France en
détruisant sa République la France n'est
pas une entreprise les Français ne sont
pas vos salariés et vous n'êtes pas leur
patron c'est l'inverse la France est une
République le souverain c'est le peuple
le patron c'est lui les employés c'est
nous et la fonction qu'il nous a confié
c'est de servir l'intérêt général madame
la Première ministre dégagez on sait
quoi faire pour vous
remplacer
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous
plaît s'il vous
plaît
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les
[Musique]
Députés il est déjà bien tard ce jeudi
soir l'émicycle est clair semé pour
débattre de cette 24e motion de censure
la 7è en moins de 2
mois aussi je me contenterai de quelques
messages d'abord pour revenir sur
l'utilisation frénétique des motions de
censure par
certains samedi dernier dans leurs
interventions les députés senseurs ont
eux-mêmes fait un aveu éloquant sont
déposé je cite bien trop de motions de
censure leur faisant ainsi perdre ce
caractère d'exception qui est pourtant
leur fonction
petit à petit plus rien n'a de poids
plus rien n'a de valeur ni de sens de
1988 à
1993 Michel Rocard éedit cresson et
Pierre bergovois n'avaient pas de
majorité absolue pour les mêmes raisons
que nous aujourd'hui ils ont dû recourir
au 493 pour permettre l'adoption de leur
budget peut-être ses noms vous
parlent-il monsieur l'orateur du groupe
socialiste sur leur projet dois de
finance la responsabilité des trois
gouvernements a été engagé à 17 reprises
en réponse combien de motions de censure
5 l'opposition était-elle moins
vigoureuse à l'époque je ne le crois pas
la démocratie parlementaire s'en
est-elle plus mal portée assurément pas
au
contraire si nous utilisons le 493
conformément à son esprit pour éviter le
blocage du pays en cas d'absence de
majorité
vous
dénaturez pardon pardon s'il vous plaît
mes chers collègues est-ce qu'on peut
respecter la premère ministre qui
intervient tout de
même c'est la dernière fois que je le
dis hein c'est la dernière fois que je
dis madame la Première ministre pouvez
poursuivre si nous utilisons le 493
conformément à son esprit pour éviter le
blocage du pays en cas d'absence de de
majorité vous dénaturez l'usage
desémotions de censure la censure
réflexe marque la fin de la censure
politique puisqueavec vous tout est
censure tout se vaut et plus rien n'a de
sens même les mots n'ont plus de
sens le parcours législatif du budget
continue il revient à l'Assemblée en
nouvelle lecture nouveau 493 et comme
d'habitude motion de
sensure la parole est est à madame la
Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président de la commission des
finances monsieur le rapporteur général
du budget Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
députés je ne vais pas m'apesantir sur
une situation qui n'a pas changé et que
chacun
connaît notre pays a besoin d'un budget
et les
ne souite pas trouver de compromis avec
nous pour
l'adopter malgré cela s'il vous plaît
madame Chikirou malgré
cela allez s'il vous plaît madame la
Première ministre à la
parole ça ne do pas être long je vous
rassure c'est comm ça malgré cela nous
n'avons pas renoncer au dialogue ce
texte a été enrichi par des amendements
de la majorité comme des oppositions à
l'Assemblée nationale comme au Sénat je
pense notamment dans cette première
partie à la réforme des zone de
revitalisation rurale adopté au Sénat
une réforme qui va permettre d'y inclure
4000 communes de plus que prévu
initialement mais alors que les délais
constitutionnels mais alors que les
délais
constitutionnels allez
mais alors que les délais
constitutionnels nous pressent et
qu'aucun groupe d'opposition n'est prêt
à voter ce budget nous devons prendre
nos
responsabilité nous ne pouvons pas
priver nos services publics de leurs
moyens nous ne pouvons pas priver notre
sécurité notre justice et nos armées de
hausse inédite de leur budget nous ne
pouvons pas priver la transition
écologique de moyens sans précédent nous
ne pouvons pas priver nos enseignants
d'une augmentation de leur salaire de
125 € minimum par mois aussi sur le
fondement de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution j'engage la responsabilité
de mon gouvernement sur la première
partie du projet de doit de finance pour
2024 je vous remercie conséquence
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion et
le vote sur cette motion de
censure le premier orateur va être
monsieur Sébastien deogu pour le groupe
la France insoumise pour une durée de 10
minutes madame la Première ministre
risque de vous étonner je veux
sincèrement vous remercier vous
remercier car en déclenchant pour la 21e
fois l'article 493 vous donner à
quelqu'un comme moi un simple habitant
des quartiers nord de notre si belles
villes de Marseille devenu aujourd'hui
député de la nation française l'occasion
de venir vous dire droit dans les yeux
et pendant 10 minutes ce que des
millions de Françaises et de français
pens de votre politique et de votre
gouvernement oui ce sont des millions de
Françaises et de Français qui aimeraient
bien en ce moment même être à ma place
vous savez celles et ceux qui font les
frais de vos décisions autoritaires que
vous leur imp posz dans votre budget
sous votre gouvernement ce sont des
millions de Français et de Français qui
ne peuvent pas couvrir leurs dépenses du
quotidien pourtant essentiel à la vie ce
sont des millions de Françaises et de
Français qui subissent le poids de la
cruauté des sacrifices du quotidien ce
sont des millions de Français de
Français qui voi les choses
simples les qui voi les prix des choses
simples mais nécessaires exploser comme
leur nourriture leur logement leurs
charges locativ la cantine pour les
enfants ou leur activités sportive et
tant d'autres choses comme les vacances
si seulement il pouvaient y songer ce
sont des millions de Françaises et de
Français qui avec la venue de l'hiver
doivent trancher entre se chauffer et
manger correctement ce sont des millions
de français et de Français qui savent
très bien qu'ils sont les premières
victimes de votre budget historiquement
autoritaire et bien eux madame la
Première ministre je vous assure qu'ils
ne vous disent pas merci et les 30
millions de travailleurs à qui vous avez
volé 2 ans de vie avec votre réforme des
retraites non plus car ils le savent
vous ne les écoutez pas comme vous ne
m'écoutez pas d'ailleurs en ce moment
vous ne les considérez pas bref vous ne
les respectez pas pourtant si vous les
écoutiez comprendriez ce qu'il vous
demande est légitime car il est normal
de vouloir une existence digne et donc
pour ça de vouloir un état qui protège
ses citoyens de la violence des marchés
financiers et pas un état qui protège
quelques-uns Vau semblables des
millionnaire et qui voi l'inflation
comme une auè de
rentabilité au fil de vos interventions
j'ai écouté les mêmes arguments entendus
et
réentendus et ce soir plusieurs d'entre
vous ont encore osé taxer le
gouvernement de déis démocratie pourtant
mesdames et messieurs les députés sansur
vos manœuvres et vos indignation surjoué
ne trompe personne avec la majorité avec
mon gouvernement nous n'avons pas de
leçon de concertation à recevoir de la
part de ceux qui refusent toute
recherche d'accord avec la avec la
majorité avec mon gouvernement nous
n'avons pas de leçon de débat à recevoir
alors même que vous répon à chaque
budget par des motions de rejet et des
motions de censure avec la majorité avec
mon gouvernement nous n'avons pas de
leçon de parlementarisme à recevoir de
la de la part de députés insoumis qui
n'ont que les outrances à la bouche avec
la majorité avec mon gouvernement nous
n'avons aucune leçon à recevoir dans la
lutte contre l'extrême droite alors que
vous vous alliez régulièrement que vous
alliez régulièrement vos voix à celle du
rassemblement national régulièrement
vous faites front commun l'extrême
gauche pour provoquer le blocage et
l'extrême droite pour en récolter les
fruits vous dites vous opposez mais dans
cette assemblée bien souvent les
extrêmes se font la courte
échelle mesdames et messieurs les
députés depuis plus de 18 mois sur tous
les textes nous avançons nous
construisons certains tentent de
rabaisser le travail parlementaire la
réalité est ailleurs le Parlement
fonctionne malgré toutes les tentative
de certains depuis plus de 18 mois nous
avons construit des majorités avec des
parlementaires de tous les groupes de
l'arc républicain près de 60 textes ont
été adoptés sans recourir au 493 des
textes importants portant des mesures
fortes encore récemment pour le plein
emploi pour le pouvoir d'achat pour le
Bien Vieillir bien sûr chacun sait qu'il
en va autrement pour les textes
budgétaires depuis les communes jusqu'à
notre Parlement V un budget et la marque
d'appartenance à une majorité ou à une
opposition je peux regretter que cet
usage nous empêche de construire un
accord sur le budget mais je ne le
conteste pas en revanche j'en tiens les
conclusions qui s'imposent et en
responsabilité j'utilise les outils que
notre Constitution nous donne nous
respectons ces principes à la lettre
comme l'a affirmé le Conseil
constitutionnel hier c'est une réponse
claire aux apprentis
constitutionnalistes du rassemblement
nationale la motion est repoussée
immédiatement un 493 est déclenché sur
la partie dépenses et on l'a compris à
chaque 493 les insoumis répondent par
une motion de
censure madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général du budget
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les
députés alors que vous venez à l'instant
pour la troisième fois sur ce projet de
loi de finance de rejeter une motion de
censure les délais constitutionnels se
rappellent à nous et tandis qu'ils se
rapprochent une chose est claire nous ne
pouvons pas nous passer d'un budget nous
ne pouvons pas nous passer d'un budget
d'investissement qui renforce l'autorité
de l'État et accorde des moyens sans
précédent à notre justice
notre pour notre sécurité et pour nos
armées nous ne pouvons pas nous passer
d'un budget vert qui porte les
investissements en faveur de la
transition écologique à 40 milliards
d'euros nous ne pouvons pas nous passer
d'un budget qui renforce nos services
publics et notamment notre école nous ne
pouvons pas nous passer d'un budget de
responsabilité conforme à notre
trajectoire de diminution des déficits
publics nous ne pouvons pas nous passer
d'un budget amendé et enrichi grâce au
travail parlementaire grâce à la
majorité et aux oppositions grâce à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat aussi
sur le fondement de l'article 49 alinéa
3 de la Constitution j'engage la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement sur
la deuxième partie et l'ensemble du
projet de loi de finances pour 2024 je
vous remercie je vous remercie madame la
Première ministre 22 voilà madame born
voilà le 493 22 passer en moins de 2 22
voilà madame borne elle embarque les
débats mais ne tape pas que 22 la
démocratie plaquée et l'austérité
planquée et oui madame borne votre bilan
se résumera peut-être à ce chiffre 22 si
vous ennuyez après le prochain
remanement vous pourrez toujours
organiser un match de foot avec vos 493
peu de premier ministres dans la 5e
République ont eu cette opportunité
toutefois il faut vous reconnaître
quelques qu chose à défaut de
démocratiser nos institutions vous aurez
démocratisé le
493 désormais tout le monde connaît cet
article en France et au-delà 22
multirécidiviste mais jamais d'aveux car
tous ces 493 et vos déboirs
parlementaires ne sont jamais de votre
fait il y a les cadeaux qu'on aurait
aimé avoir vous savez ça se passe à
chaque Noël on aimerait des cadeau et
puis n'arrive pas ce qui nous permettrai
pourtant de bâtir une société plus juste
et combaattive au dérèglement climatique
le rétablissement de l'exit taxe un
grand plan de 1,5 milliard d'euros pour
un plan du ferroviaire la titularisation
des contractuels dans le service public
12 milliards d'euros pour la rénovation
thermique des logements s'attaquer au
surprofit responsable de l'inflation
permettre aux collectivités d'avoir une
dotation globale de fonctionnement au
niveau de celle-ci indexer les salaires
sur l'inflation au lieu de cela vous
préférez laisser le pays dans la
dépression et l'austérité les dépenses
du budget général de l'État sont en
baisse de 4,2 milliards d'euros il
s'agit d'une austérité
historique allez s'il vous plaît on
laisse parler madame la Première
ministre dans le calme s'il vous plaît
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les
Députés s'il vous
plaît en écoutant les censeurs se
succéder à la
tribune comm bien
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas à la tribune vous n'avez
pas la parole s'il vous plaît vous
laissez madame la Première ministre
exprimer en écoutant les censeurs se
succéder à la tribune mais vous viendrez
à l'idée parfois de respecter les
orateurs allez s'il vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plaîtz en écant less se succédait à la
tribune motion après motion pour prendre
les mêmes postures et égrener les mêmes
contevérités je me suis rappelé qu'il y
a un an je m'étais interrogé sur ce que
les historiens retiendraient de ces
débats
budgétaires les les amateurs d'histoire
constitutionnelle se demanderont sans
doute pourquoi ceux qui n'avaient pas
hésité par le passé à utiliser le
493 faisit semblant de croire qu'il
s'agissait d'une menace pour la
démocratie il ils s'interrogeront aussi
sans doute sur ce qui a pu pousser
l'extrême gauche à dénaturer la portée
des motions de censure en les déposant
ad nooséam sans que rien ne les y
oblige les spécialistes de l'histoire de
la gauche s'interrogeront sans doute sur
la bascule
sémantique qui a conduit à remplacer au
sein des discours de la nupè les idées
par les invectives j'assume de porter un
budget de responsabilité qui respecte
notre trajectoire budgétaire et prolonge
la baisse de nos déficit public au
moment où nous devons veiller à garder
pleinement la maîtrise de notre
souveraineté nous ne pouvons pas nous en
passer motion de censure après motion de
censure laanupes s convaincu qu'en
répétant des mensonges il deviendrait
des vérités mais la réalité est claire
les chiffres sont indiscutables nous
nous investis sont partout où il faut
nous ne serons jamais le camp de
l'austérité en revanche mesdames et
messieurs les députés sensur je vous le
demande comment pouvez-vous justifier
auprès de nos concitoyens que vous vous
opposez à la création de 2300 poste de
policiers et gendarmes pour l'année
prochaine comment pouvez-vous justifier
auprès des femmes que vous vous opposez
à la création d'une aide universelle
d'urgence pour les victimes de violence
conjugale comment pouvez-vous justifier
auprès des enseignant que vous refusez
une hausse de leur salaire de 125 €
minimum par mois comment pouvez-vous
justifier auprès des jeunes qui
s'engagent pour le climat que vous
voulez rejeter 40 milliards d'euros pour
la transition écologique nous avons
construit un budget de justice de
protection de préparation de notre
avenir un budget responsable mais qui
investit dans les fondamentaux c'est
cela que les Français attendent c'est
cela que les français demandent et c'est
cela que nous sommes déterminés à leur
donner je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie mardi 19 décembre c'est le
dernier 493 nécessaire pour faire
adopter le texte en lecture
définitive l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion en lecture définitive du
projet de loi de finances pour
2024 la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général du budget
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les
députés nous voilà arrivés au terme de
ce nouvel exercice
budgétaire comme l'année dernière avec
la majorité avec mon gouvernement nous
avons tendu la main aux oppositions et
tenté de trouver des points d'accord
comme l'année dernière nous avons fait
évoluer notre texte grâce à des
amendements de la majorité comme des
oppositions de l'Assemblée nationale
comme du Sénat et je veux ici saluer le
travail mené par tous les parlementaires
qui ont cherché à enrichir ce texte dans
un état d'esprit constructif mais comme
l'année dernière les oppositions restent
sur leur position de principe ne pas
voter le budget quel qu'en soit le
contenu aussi pour donner des moyens
inédit à notre
sécurité notre justice et nos armées
pour permettre des investissements sans
précédent dans la transition
écologique pour augmenter le salaire des
enseignants pour accroître la DGF de nos
communes pour respecter notre engagement
de ne pas augmenter les impôts ou encore
pour nous inscrire dans une trajectoire
de réduction de nos déficits
publics sur le fondement de l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution j'engage la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement sur
l'ensemble du projet de doie de finance
pour 2024 je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la Première
ministre la motion de censure est
rejetée le projet de loi de finance pour
2024 est définitivement adopté il aura
fallu 5 493
c'est la fin de ce numéro des grands
débats à très vite sur
LCP